I've been playing around with various
frameworks for at least the past eight
years all these frameworks foundation
bootstrap blueprint they've only really
existed at least for me to disguise the
fact that CSS layout until now has been
pretty much a hack float or floats were
the best thing we had at the time but
they weren't designed for full page
layout they were designed for this
floating an image next to some text and
that's pretty much all they were meant
to do so because of this faking a grid
with floats requires careful
calculations setting margins lots of
debugging in different browsers and it
results in pages that easily break when
the content changes or when the content
isn't what the designer originally or
developer expected and the frameworks
that we've many of us have probably been
using hid away a lot of this complexity
a few years ago it seemed like flexbox
was going to change all this and in some
ways it did now suddenly we could put
elements side by side make them equal
height without resorting to hard-coded
Heights or JavaScript so that was nice
we could also easily do this without any
trickery or JavaScript we could even
wrap things on multiple rows but using
flexbox to build a grid in two
dimensions is also a hack so then those
frameworks we were using just transition
to flexbox
we had CSS frameworks with flexbox
foundation moved to flexbox bootstrap I
believe also moved to using flexbox so
that they were better frameworks because
of flexbox but it was still a hack so
how is CSS grid different CSS grid had
just appeared in the past year and it's
been implemented at an astonishing speed
i CSS grid as a topic is far too large
for me to go through I can't go through
all of it but I'm going to go through
the basics and then a few examples and
then talk about what that means in my
opinion for the future so let's have a
look at a simple example using the
traditional 12 column grid we've all
been using we've got three elements we
want to place on the grid four columns
each now using flexbox we'd do something
like this this is an example from the
foundation framework but it could could
be from any framework really we're
setting display flex on the parent
element grid X in in this example then
we are setting some padding's on the
individual cells and then we've set a
width so if you look at the view bottom
rows there we're setting the width to 33
point 33 percent and then subtracting
the the padding's now let's do the same
thing with grid now we're setting
display grid on the parent item okay
that's not that much different from
flexbox but the big difference is that
now we've defined that we're defining
the grid itself so if you look at the
the class grid in in this bits of CSS
we've got a new
property there grid template columns
which has odd value repeat 12 1fr we'll
go into what that is in the next slides
and then we are setting a grid gap and
then right at the bottom we are setting
the small for class which is really just
I wanted to use the same markup as as in
the foundation example we're setting
that to span four columns but the big
difference is that now we're not
calculating any width we're just saying
I want this to be four columns wide so
let's look at how to define a grid in
more detail grid template columns and
its counterpart grid template rows allow
you to define arbitrary tracks tracks is
a track is a generic term for column or
row by the way so here we're creating a
200 pixel wide column and another 800
pixel wide column and these are
obviously fixed width columns now this
example changes the second column to
flexible width CSS grid introduces a new
fr unit which means fraction of the
available space so in this case the grid
algorithm in the browser reserves 200
pixels for the first column and then it
looks at the remaining space and says ok
it says one fraction and that's we've
only got one column left so we're going
to give all that rest of all the space
that's left to to the second column and
the cool thing about the fraction unit
is that we can just add a second column
like this which is also 1 fr because now
we have two columns that need to split
the the available space so first the
browser is calculating one plus one and
then dividing that
into two and then splitting it up for
the equally to the two columns so if I
were to change the second column to two
fr now it's twice the size as the than
the third column now back to my original
example if I want a twelve column grid I
could say grid template columns one F R
1 F R 1 F R and so on but there's a
really handy repeat notation to do that
in much shorter amount of code now in
this example I don't I'm only repeating
one column but I also could be repeating
a pattern of columns so I could have
repeat 12 1 fr 50 pixels for example and
then you have every other column would
be one fraction of what was all
available and then every other column
would be a fixed fixed 50 pixels and
like I said it has a counterpart grid
template rose which works exactly the
same so here I'm creating a 200 pixel
header row and then the rest is
allocated to whatever the content needs
as a minimum there's also a max content
keyword and there's loads more of these
keywords in CSS grid and I haven't got
time to go through all of them
unfortunately but it means we get a lot
of flexibility in defining rows and
columns now we also don't need to set
margins or padding's to fake gutters
anymore because CSS grid has its own
property for this grid gap it's a
shorthand property for grid row gap and
grid column gap which means you can
define them separately if you want want
to have a different gutter width between
the C of the grid tracks for columns and
rows in the first one there is 4 rows
and the second one is 4 columns in the
spec the
this has already been changed to GAAP
which hopefully means that we might get
this in flexbox later on but that hasn't
happened yet but you should still use
grid gap because current browsers still
don't support the short notation and
browsers will probably be supporting the
supporting the old version for a long
time
so to recap to defy to create a grid we
say display grid then we define our
tracks with grid template columns or
grid template rows or both and then if
we want to we can define a gap with grid
gap now okay what we've done so far is
nothing we couldn't do with flexbox or
floats it's more robust but we could
still do it with old techniques but what
about this with Flex box or display
float we'd probably have to create more
wrapper containers and maybe do some
height calculations with JavaScript or
then set fixed Heights and hope that the
content doesn't break the layout with
grid all we need to do is this at the
bottom there I've set them given the
first cell a class big one and said grid
row span too so I want this element to
span two rows and that's it and now it
magically takes up the height of those
two roads regardless of the content in
those other rows and at the top I've
also defined grid auto rows to 200
pixels a grid Auto rows and grid Auto
columns is another CSS grid property
that allows you to say if if we need to
create additional rows or columns that
weren't defined in my original
definition they should be this size
because it's possible for the grid to
overflow if we it might be that we've
defined only one row but then we set an
element
to span two rows so the Browse house to
know what to do so this case it looks
okay we want those rows to be 200 pixels
that could be anything it could be 10
a.m. or it could be min content or
something else there are many ways to
define a grid and to place things on a
grid there's line based notation named
lines grid template areas defining using
named lines and referencing by area and
there's also auto placement which we
were using in our first example now the
most basic form is line based so here
I've got four items placed on to a grid
and let's look at item number to sell to
in more detail so you can see from the
image that I want that to go from line
number seven to line number 13 and by
the way obviously this is a 12 column
grid but that that means you have 13
lines so we're not talking about the
tracks themselves we're talking about
the lines in between so to place an item
into a specific place on the grid we
could say we want this to start from
line number 7 grid columns start 7 and
we want it to span and up to line number
13 so I say grid column end 13 and
there's also a handy short notation for
that grid column and grid row
respectively and this is the full code
for that previous example now like I
said line numbers are the most basic way
of laying items on a grid but they can
be a bit cumbersome and hard to maintain
if you ever make changes to your grid so
named lines are a bit more handy such as
here I want the content in the middle
column and then I want one item to span
the full which of
width of the page so we continue as in
our previous example but now I've added
names for the lines in between my track
definitions so I use angle brackets in
between the tracks to give names for my
lines and they can be anything I want
and you can have multiple names per line
for various purposes so it's you can
think of them like CSS classes but
defined in CSS itself so then placing
items onto the grid works exactly the
same as with using line numbers but you
use the names instead and it's more
flexible because then if you go and add
a line somewhere you don't have to
change the numbers again but what's
really cool is named areas so I can also
do this there's this handy definition
for grid template areas where I draw a
kind of ASCII map of our grid and let's
look at that in more detail each row is
delimited by quotation marks and each
cell of the grid has a keyword to
represent it and those can be anything I
want so basically this says that I've
got a logo on the left then I've got a
navigation that spans two columns then
I've got content that spans two columns
in the second row I've got an aside
which spans one column in the second row
and then a footer which spans the whole
of the third row and when I want to
place something into an area I just say
grid area logo and it goes there and
that's that now why this is especially
cool is when you make changes to your
layout based on the size the width of
the container whatever all I need to do
yes this is the whole code for for
placing the elements onto the grid
so when I want to make responsive
changes to the layout all I need to do
is redefine the grid and I don't need to
don't necessarily need to touch the
items at all which potentially makes my
code much much more simple so there's
lots to know about defining grids and
placing things on the grid and I
recommend you read the spec to find out
more so do we still need frameworks
they've mostly served to hide the
happiness of CSS layout until now and in
my opinion as a developer who has been
using frameworks mostly out of
convenience I'd say that going forward
they can only limit the potential of
what we can do with flexbox and CSS grid
and many other layout methods depending
on the right use case so we'll probably
we might need frameworks for for some
purposes and there I can still see them
as being useful for prototyping or
people who maybe back-end developers who
don't have a clue about CSS and just
want to get something a nice user
interface quickly but if you are a
front-end developer or someone who
thinks you should know CSS then I think
you should put those frameworks behind
you and and start learning CSS layout
deeply now CSS grid is not going to
replace all these other layout methods
it's it just means that now we can use
floats and multi-column layout and
flexbox and also display table for what
they were originally meant to do but
what about old browsers browser support
is actually pretty good the
implementation across modern browsers is
amazingly stable IE 10 and 11 however
along with some old versions of edge
support an older version of the spec and
it's missing quite a few of the property
of the new spec so it will depend on the
project you're working on whether it's
worth it to to also write things in that
older to write code in that older spec
so that would depend on the project I'd
say most of the time probably not so
just a quick example of doing something
with CSS grid with a fallback I want to
create a gallery like this and I want
some of the images to span multiple
columns and all rows I could start with
an inline block style grid well it's not
really agreed I'm just saying that I
want these to be inline block and have a
certain maximum width and this should
work in the oldest of browsers and then
I can enhance it with CSS grid by
defining defining the grid and then
adding a few additional styles to the
elements I want to span multiple columns
or rows and in this example I'm using
auto placement which is the default way
CSS grid works if you don't set a
specific place for an item on the grid
it will just go to the next cell on the
grid available which is very handy for
cases like this where you don't
necessarily know how many items you have
beforehand there are some accessibility
concerns with CSS grid so as you can
probably imagine because you can place
elements basically anywhere you want on
the grid the visual layout of your page
can quickly become out of sync from the
source order of your page and because
CSS grid doesn't change the tabbing
order of your page people using just a
keyboard to navigate can quickly become
confused so it's your responsibility to
make sure that doesn't have
there are loads of resources for reading
up on CSS grid
everything written by Rachel Andrew is
is superb that's mostly how I learnt CSS
grid myself her website grid by example
is is great it's got loads of example
patterns with full fallbacks for older
browsers the mozilla documentation is is
great I suggest you also read the spec
it's I was surprised myself how easy it
was to read compared to some earlier
experiences on reading w3 specs Jenn
Simmons has a great website with with
some CSS grid experiments and Rachel
Andrew just came out with a book on a
book apart which is pretty short and
really summarizes everything we can do
today with with CSS layout it's not only
about CSS grid so I'm from the Zealand
family have we got time for a couple of
questions thank you
[Applause]